Now that we know how to import our character and animations, let's jump in and take a look at our
character in the engine and check out the different animation subeditors to see how we can
preview our animations and get a basic understanding of how to navigate through
the different animation editors and what you can do within each one.
To preview our character in the engine we want to open up the skeletal mesh
and you can see that's one of these pink icons just here and you can tell that just because
it says skeletal mesh at the bottom of the icon or if you hover over it
it'll also tell you it's a skeletal mesh just in brackets at the top there.
So if we double click this, this opens up our skeletal mesh editor.
Now this is where we can preview our skeleton, our character which has the skeleton here
and it has the mesh that we have skinned to it.
Now this is also where you would assign the materials for your character.
So just down here in the asset details you can assign any materials that you might have
as well as LOD information that you might need to set up for your character just below.
You can also see you've got access to your skeleton tree here so you can see all of the
bones for your characters or any sockets that you might have set up to attach things
to your characters you'd find in here as well.
And another useful window here is the morph target preview window.
So this allows you to preview any morph targets that you've got set up for your character.
So if you set up any blend shapes in an external software and brought them into the engine
this is where you'd be able to preview them and turn them on and off and see
whether or not they're working correctly.
And along the top right of the toolbar here you'll see we've got a few different icons.
Now these give you access to the other animation sub editor windows.
So whenever you're in one of these windows you will always have these icons at the top
to give you access to the other windows.
So we can jump through to the skeleton, we can see any animations,
any animation blueprints or physics assets that are related to this
skeletal mesh that we have open.
So if we jump into the skeleton here this is where you would access and edit your skeleton.
So on the left hand side here you can see all the bones that are in your skeleton.
You can select any of these and you can manipulate them and just see how your message
mesh is deforming.
You could also attach or create sockets should I say for your skeleton which is what you'd
use to attach items to your character.
Whether that's at runtime or through sequences or however you want to do that.
You can also preview attachments inside this window here as well if you have a socket.
Now on the right hand side here you have your preview scene settings tab.
So if you have multiple skeletal meshes that are using the same skeleton
this is where you could change the preview for those.
So you can see on the right hand side here we've got two different skeletal meshes that
use this same skeleton.
Now we can swap between those and see what that preview looks like.
And again you can just manipulate the joints there just to see how that deformation works.
And on the bottom right here we have the asset browser.
Now this is where you can access animations or blend spaces or montages that are being
used with this skeleton or the skeletal mesh.
Now if we double click and open up one of these animation sequences here
you can see that it automatically opens up this animation sequence editor window.
And you can see that on the top right here with the the icon that's highlighted.
This is where you would preview your animations.
So inside here again you've got access to your skeleton tree.
You can see all the the joints if you need those.
There's also the asset details tab.
So this is where you could modify or edit any animation related properties.
So you could change the rate scale and make the animation quicker or slow it down.
You could also activate or deactivate root motion.
So if your animation has root motion you can turn that on and off just here.
And a host of other animation related properties.
You also have access again to the preview scene settings tab.
So we could change that to be Quinn again and just see that animation
is looking with that character.
If you're perhaps trying to use the same animation with multiple characters
just make sure it looks good and it's working with the multiple characters that you have.
And along the bottom here is the timeline.
So this is obviously where you can scrub through the animation forwards and backwards.
You can add notifies.
So these green icons here which just trigger code essentially to do something at runtime.
You can also access the curves related to this character that might be
blend shape curves or they could be bone tracks that you have set up for your character.
You'll be able to see that in the window just down the bottom here.
And again you have the asset browser.
So again if you have another animation that you want to jump to you could just double click
open any of those up and also things like blend spaces so you could preview those here.
So if I hit play here we can go from the slow walk to the standard walk and then
blend into the run so you can preview all that stuff in here as well.
Now something else you can do which isn't immediately clear if I just jump back to one of
the animations rather than the blend space is you can actually edit this animation in sequencer.
So if you hit these two little arrows at the top here choose editing sequencer
and then edit with fk control rig that'll then give you an option to bake this down to
the fk control rig within a sequencer.
So if I click bake to control rig and I go to our level here we can see that as we scrub
through this our animation has been baked down to this control rig here.
So what I could do is grab one of these controls which just represent each bone in the
body and maybe I can just grab a few of these and delete them and add a new key where
he raises his arm and you'll see that as I scrub through this the arm now raises up and
down and what you can do with that if I just scrub back to the top is right click the
character and bake animation sequence and that just means we can save this as a new
animation or we could even overwrite the existing animation and it's just a really nice way and
a quick way of making edits to existing animations that you have inside the project.
Now we do have a lot of other courses that go over sequencer and control rigs in much more
detail so be sure to check those out if that's something that you want to learn more about.
Our next animation editor window is the animation blueprint so if we click this icon just
up here here we have the animation blueprint which is essentially a tool which controls the
animations of the skeletal mesh by allowing you to blend animations control bones
and create different logic that essentially defines the final animation pose.
So in here we've got two main graphs we have the event graph and the anim graph.
So if I double click that here's the event graph and this is similar to a regular blueprint
where you can handle different events and variables and logic that would trigger a change
in state of the animation and then you have the anim graph. Now this is where you would define
the final animation output pose so where you can control the blending of the animations
set up state machines and things that basically determine the final animation output pose.
So essentially the event graph takes information like player input and then passes that along
to the anim graph and the anim graph determines what animation should be playing based on that
input. And finally we have the physics editor window just at the top right here. Now this is
where you would create and edit any of the collision bodies that will be used for your
skeletal mesh in relation to any physics that you have going on in your project.
So maybe you want to make your character ragdoll or have things bump into your character you'd
use this window here to edit all of these physics bodies that you can see adding and
deleting from the skeleton tree on the left hand side here and then readjusting and repositioning
in the viewport to make sure they fit your character mesh properly and to ensure that things
react correctly with the mesh.